so the other wondered what it would be
like to live in a place with no rules
that sounds pretty cool
we wake up one morning however and you
discover that the reason there are no
rules is because there's no government
and there are no laws in fact all social
institutions have disappeared so there's
no schools there's no hospitals there's
no police there's no banks
there's no Athletic Club there's no
utilities well I know a little bit about
what this is like because when I was a
medical student in 1999 I worked in a
refugee camp in the Balkans during the
Kosovo war and when the war was over I
got permission unbelievably from my
medical school to take some time off and
follow some of the families that I had
befriended in the camp back to their
village in Kosovo and understand how
they navigated life in this post-war
setting so post-war Kosovo was a very
interesting place because NATO troops
were there mostly to make sure that the
war didn't break out again but other
than that it was actually a lawless
place and almost every social
institution both public and private had
been destroyed so I can tell you that
when you go into one of these situations
and settings it is absolutely thrilling
for about 30 minutes because that's
about how long it takes before you run
into a situation where you realize how
incredibly vulnerable you are for me
that moment came when I had to cross the
first checkpoint and I realized that as
I drove up that I would be negotiating
passage through this checkpoint with a
heavily armed individual who if he
decided to shoot me
right then and there he actually
wouldn't be doing anything illegal but
the sense of vulnerability that I had
was absolutely nothing in comparison to
the vulnerability of the families that I
got to know over that year you see life
in a society where there are no social
institutions is riddled with danger and
uncertainty in simple questions like
what are we going to eat tonight are
very complicated to answer questions
about security when you don't have any
security systems are terrifying that
altercation my head with that neighbor
down the block i'ma turn into a violent
episode that will end my life or my
family's life health concerns when there
is no Health System are also terrifying
I listen as many families had to sort
through questions like my infant has a
fever what am I going to do my sister
who is pregnant is bleeding what should
I do
who should I turn to where are the
doctors where are the nurses if I could
find one are they trustworthy how will I
pay them in what currency will I pay
them if I need medications where will I
sign them if I take those medications
are they actually counterfeits and on
and on so life in these settings the
dominant theme the dominant feature of
life is the incredible vulnerability
that people have to manage day in and
day out because of the lack of social
systems and it actually turns out that
this feature of life is incredibly
difficult to explain and be understood
by people who are living outside of it
so I discovered this when I left Kosovo
I came back to Boston I became a
physician I became a global public
health policy researcher I joined the
Harvard Medical School and Brigham and
Women's Hospital Division of global
health and I as a researcher really want
to get started on this problem right
away like how do we reduce the crushing
vulnerability of people living in these
types of fragile settings
is there any way that we can start to
think about how to protect and quickly
recover the institutions that are
critical to survival like the health
system and I have to say I have amazing
colleagues okay but one interesting
thing about it was that this was sort of
an unusual question for them here kind
of um you know if you work in war does
that mean you work on refugee camps and
work on documenting mass atrocities
which is by the way very very very
important
so it took me a while for to explain why
I was so passionate about this issue
until about six years ago and that's
when this landmark study that looked at
and described the public health
consequences of war was published and
they came to a incredible provocative
conclusion these researchers concluded
that the vast majority of death and
disabilities from war happens after the
cessation of conflict so the most
dangerous time to be a person living in
a conflict affected states it's after
the cessation of hostilities is after
the peace deal has been signed is when
that political solution has been
achieved that seems so puzzling but of
course it's not because war kills people
by robbing them of their clinics of
their hospitals of their supply chains
their doctors are targeted are kills are
on the run and more invisible and yet
more deadly is the destruction of the
health governance institutions and their
finances so this is really not
surprising at all to me but what is
surprising and somewhat dismaying is how
little impact this insight has had in
terms of how we think about human
suffering and more let me give you a
couple examples last year you may
remember that Ebola hit the West African
country of Liberia and there was a lot
of reporting about this group Doctors
Without Borders sounding the alarm and
calling for aid and assistance but not a
lot of that reporting answered the
question why you stuff is Without
Borders even in Liberia that's all
border
is an amazing organization dedicated and
designed to providing emergency care and
war zones
Liberia's Civil War had ended in 2003
that was 11 years before Ebola even
struck when Ebola struck Liberia there
were less than 50 doctors in the entire
country of 4.5 million people Doctors
Without Borders in Liberia because
Liberia still doesn't really have a
functioning health system only 11 years
later when the earthquake hit Haiti in
2010 the outpouring of international aid
was phenomenal but did you know that
only 2% of that funding went to rebuild
Haitian public institutions including
its health sector from that perspective
patients continue to die from the
earthquake even today I recently met
this gentleman this is dr. Nazir Ismet
he's the minister of health in the
northern autonomous region of Iraq and
Kurdistan here he is announcing met the
last nine months his country his region
has increased from 4 million people to 5
million people at the 25% increase
thousands of these new arrivals have
experienced incredible trauma his
doctors are working 16-hour days without
pay his budget has not increased by 25
percent it has decreased by 20% as
funding has flowed security concerns and
to short-term relief efforts when his
health sector fails and if history is
any guide it will how do you think
that's going to influence the
decision-making of the five million
people in his region as they think about
whether they should flee that type of
vulnerable living situation so as you
can see this is a frustrating topic for
me and I really try to understand why
the reluctance to protest and support
indigenous health systems and security
systems when I usually tier two concerns
two arguments the first concern is about
corruption and the concern that people
in these settings are corrupt and they
are untrustworthy and I will admit that
I have met unsaved
characters working in health sectors and
new situations but I will tell you that
the opposite is absolutely true in every
case I have worked on from Afghanistan
to Libya to Kosovo to Haiti to Liberia I
have met inspiring people who when the
chips were down for their country they
risked everything to save their health
institutions the trick for the outsider
who wants to help is identifying who
those individuals are and building a
pathway for them to lead and that is
exactly what happened in Afghanistan one
of the unsung and untold stories of our
nation building effort in Afghanistan
involved the World Bank in 2002
investing heavily in identifying
training and promoting Afghani health
sector leaders these health sector
leaders have pulled off an incredible
feat in Afghanistan they have
aggressively increased access to health
care for the majority of the population
they are rapidly improving the health
status of the Afghan population which
used to be the worst in the world in
fact Danskin Ministry of Health does
things that I wish we would do in
America they use things like data to
make policy it's incredible
the other concern I hear a lot about is
we just can't afford it we just we just
have the money it's just unsustainable I
would submit to you that the current
situation and the current system we have
is the most expensive inefficient system
we could possibly conceive of the
current situation is that when
governments like the US or let's say the
collection of governments that make up
the European Commission every year they
spend fifteen billion dollars on just
humanitarian and emergency and disaster
relief worldwide yes nothing about
foreign aid that's just disaster relief
ninety-five percent of it goes to
international relief agencies that then
have to import resources into these
areas and knit together some type of
temporary health system let's say and
then we're stages mantle and send away
when they run out of money so our job it
turns out it's very clear we as the
global health community policy experts
our first job is we need to become
experts in what and how to monitor the
strengths and vulnerabilities of health
systems and threatened situations okay
and that's when we see doctors fleeing
when we see health resources drying up
when we see institutions crumbling
that's the emergency that's when we need
to sound the alarm and wave our arms
okay not now everyone can see that's an
emergency they don't need us to tell
them that okay number two places like
where I work at Harvard need to take
your cue from the World Bank experience
in Afghanistan and we need and we will
build robust platforms to support health
sector leaders like these okay these
people risk their lives I think we can
match their courage with some support
number three we need to reach out and
make new partnerships at our global
health center we have launched a new
initiative with NATO and other security
policymakers to explore with them what
can they do to protect health system
institutions during deployments we want
them to see that protecting
health systems and other critical social
institutions is an integral part of
their mission it's not just about
avoiding collateral damage it's about
winning the piece but the most important
partner we need to engage is you okay
the American public and indeed the world
public because unless you understand the
value of social institutions like health
systems in these fragile settings you
won't support efforts to save them you
won't click on that article that talks
about hey all those doctors are on the
run and country X I wonder what that
means I wonder what that means
for that health systems ability to let's
say detect influenza hmm probably not
good if that's what I tell you stop on
the screen I've put up my three favorite
American institution defenders and
builders ever here is George C Marshall
he was the guy that proposed the
Marshall Plan to save all of Europe's
economic institutions after World War
two and this is Eleanor Roosevelt her
work on human rights really serves as
the foundation for all of our
international human rights organizations
then my big favorite has been Franklin
who did many things in terms of creating
institutions but was the Midwife
of our Constitution and it would say to
you that these are folks that when our
country was threatened or our world with
friends they didn't retreat didn't talk
about building walls they talked about
building institutions for it to protect
human security for their generation and
also for ours and I think our generation
should do the same thank
[Applause]